have you ever claimed to be sick when
you weren't yes
proof let's not get me fired over this
today I'm taking a polygraph test I have
no idea what they're gonna ask me I know
it's something to do with work I have
never taken a lie-detector test before
I'm a little nervous but I feel like a
truthful person I don't think I've ever
done anything too bad sometimes I think
I'm too blunt and what you think is a
problem I hope I don't get in trouble I
think that I will be able to beat the
machine because it might think that I'm
lying about something but I'm gonna be
100% truthful all right strap me in
have you ever taken snacks from the
office to have at home yes that's true
yeah I take stuff every day I feel like
everybody does though so I don't know if
that's really a big deal no July does it
count as taking a snack home if it's
something that you started here and
finish it at home it wasn't like a
direct like okay that soda I'm just
gonna take those home with me and eat
them there directly it wasn't
premeditated
well that's hell yeah that's true I
wanted Oreos have you ever taken office
supplies yes I have I've taken notepads
and sticky pads that's true on accident
that's a lie I can't recall an exact
time I like stole a notepad but you know
no crew well I mean let's be quite
honest how often do any of us really
need a stapler or a three-hole punch
lovely staples things anymore
you know nobody uses paper clips do you
ever check social media at work yeah
crew all the time you know you need a
freaking bike sometimes my dude yeah I
do
definitely crew I think that's like part
of the BuzzFeed world though we all kind
of attuned to Twitter and Facebook
absolutely that's true every now and
then I just like to keep up with the
world and nowadays I mean like even the
news is technically social media have
you ever online shops when you were
supposed to be working yes true
sometimes it's for a video and then I'll
get distracted and just start shopping
for me no that's a lie
I mean I'm all my shops when I'm at home
working from home I guess you're right
but not at the office too dangerous
there's too many people around me I
don't want to see what I'm buying I
think so but part of my job is to
research things for what I do so
technically I am shopping for myself
also because I look at something and say
like yeah that was
so the answer yes I have online shop
while working that's true
have you ever watched Netflix or Hulu on
the job yes
crew I think during the internship there
would be some downtime and I would need
to catch up on bachelor or else I would
be out of the loop you know you could
argue that that's part of my job yes
true yeah I went through a Naruto kick
for a bit so I was watching other Naruto
when there was nothing to do in the
office I'll put it on for like 15 or 20
minutes while I'm in between a meeting
or something yes true and the reason for
that is sometimes you'll set up a
machine no shall I it's very interesting
that machine tells me that I'm lying
because I've never claimed to be sick
and you know taking a day off yeah
that's true but I didn't fake the cancer
have you ever faked an emergency to get
out of a prior commitment no true if I
were going through an actual emergency I
would want people to take my word for it
and I know that a lot of my team members
and whatnot really do take that stuff
very seriously absolutely true I've had
have had situations in which I had to
fake an emergency but once I was on date
but for work I haven't ever done that
plus I also feel bad because you know
like when you say like oh my god you
know grandma died and then you like
ditch work and then she actually does
that you'd be like oh my god I caused
grandma to die no true yeah that's too
bad I'm a good girl that's a lie T have
you ever not gotten along with your goal
in this
yes I have not gone along with some of
my coworkers true but it's never been
anything serious where I thought to
bring HR in or like had any like petty
arguments or anything like that yeah
true well you're gonna come across
people with different communication
styles and personality traits and
sometimes they clash it's a little like
high school that's okay
yes it's very circumstantial though crew
so a lot of the times you're working
with someone and get along really well
but then they do something and so you
end up getting very grumpy or upset at
them and you just kind of want to talk
to them and they you're sitting next to
them so you're just like very short when
they're like hey hurry I'm good just
busy back to taking the test was fine I
don't think I was super nervous just
because even when I do do something
wrong like I'm comfortable being honest
about it
she calls herself an honest person but
honest people don't take Oreos home oh
my god I'm getting dragged by John lie
detector man I probably exposed a little
bit about myself which I probably
shouldn't have exposed but hopefully
none of my managers see this so I get
away with it
this guy's a grand-slam he steals
company food he steals company supplies
and he steals company time I think it's
very circumstantial and very contextual
because while you may be thinking in
yourself like you may have some doubt
about something it may pick that up as a
lie whereas when you're very certain and
confident about something it can pick
that up is the truth to be honest I
don't think I would be able to get past
most this test without you know telling
the truth i sat down and got strapped up
and immediately started sweating so just
being in the chair makes you be like did
I do something wrong like I must have I
feel pretty confident that I could be a
second test if I'm just confident in
being firm and what I truly believe
[Music]
[Music]